even if the temperatures aren't quite
playing along yet shop windows in
European cities like here in Munich are
already showing the new spring trends
like a new romance they promise to
revive life after the dark cold months
of winter knocking winter after winter
you're tired of being buried in heavy
clothing always wearing a scarf and
tucking your hair into a hat in spring
you can finally emerge again comme
condos oh there's a mood of new
beginnings I always want new clothes you
buy the nutrients where'd you read in
the magazines and then you just decide
yeah that's cool and I want to use them
revealing the season's latest trends is
Isabelle bounds job the Munich
journalist writes for the high fashion
online magazine motor pilot with 100,000
hits a month it won at Germany's leading
internet fashion magazines as animals
con sistema Xena script saw horses there
are major long-term trends and then
there are sub trends that the designers
have show their collections in Milan and
Paris take up there's often a lot of
overlap where we say we've seen this on
a lot of people so we see a trend here
the companies that mass-produce clothing
often get their inspiration here Vivian
lesson the first trend of the new season
will definitely need warmer temperatures
the off-the-shoulder look is back with a
vengeance more pronounced than we've
seen it in decades and he didn't spend
team effort in a huge trench theme for
the summer is the shoulder the shoulder
is the new decollete it will be
emphasized in many ways either with big
sleeves or patches or with the opposite
with bare shoulders that would be very
popular and spread very quickly because
it's so uncomplicated it doesn't depend
on size and it's a chance to show a
little skin without exposing too much
that's a few to imprison
the second big trend this spring has
been driven by a single fashion house
Gucci since early 2015 designer
Alessandro michaeli has been creative
director of the italian luxury label his
wildly patent retro designs with their
ironic dapper twist on down dienes the
turning of fashion world upside down
Isabelle Brown finds examples of Gucci
fication as she calls it at the
traditional dude fake bag department
store in Munich these clothes are a bit
more conventional than on the catwalks
but here two patterns are being combined
that would never have been put together
before
momma sang decision this takes the trend
to an extreme probably only true
fashionistas will dare to wear these
patterns but as with any trend you have
to simply look for yourself and select
what fits you it could be detailed
flower prints which we call meal flower
prints and it doesn't have to be as
extreme as an animal skin pattern it can
be a little subtler dick tells the third
big trend for 2016 is gender bending the
distinctions between typical men's and
women's clothing are steadily
disappearing it's I'm vice here's an
example this is a very feminine color
pink but the cut is actually rather
masculine this is a pantsuit which is
big with women right now many women are
wearing them and then it's combined with
a top that's not low-cut but with a
fairly classic men's shirt yeah and had
on him this trend is found in all the
major designers collections while
masculinity is becoming established for
women the designs for men are getting
softer more sensual and more playful
is there MIT is the man with the average
fashion sense ready for this probably
not it will take a while with men's
fashions in general the cycles are much
slower than in women's fashions where
there is constantly new input nine input
give fresh ideas to liven up your
wardrobe no season is better suited to
that than springtime
you